you guys come see me this week the 26th
and 27th in my hometown philadelphia at
the punch line it's going to be
absolutely incredible i cannot wait then
you can see me at the irvine improv for
one night on december 2nd i'll be in new
jersey at bananas comedy club december
16th through 18th milwaukee improv
january 21st through 22nd my austin
dates got moved to august i have a bunch
coming up please go to
annieletterman.comshows
hey you guys i am coming to salt lake
city january 14th and 15th get tickets
at estronize.com and i'm also coming to
austin texas february 24th to 26th come
see me at cap city comedy club
estheronice.com today's episode
there you go
and sleepoverbaster.com annie is wearing
it today and it looks very cute on her
buy my merch
[Music]
are we in some sort of like sec there's
like a it's a sexual undertones but like
there's like some sort of struggle it's
a sexual struggle who's going to make
the first move on each other
i'ma pee today guys
does look hot and this is annoying oh
yeah this is offensive
i look like a green clan member
who am i going after what race am i
going after you're going after all
vegetables you hate kale i hate vegans
what race is associated with green jews
money you hate jews oh no irish well oh
no you like jews because clansmen wear
white because they like white people
right
well do i like i should know better they
marched in my hometown skokie illinois
they that's oh my god you're so cool i
know the kkk chose our town because
we're the most holocaust survivors and
the aclu fought for them for the aclu
gave the kkk the freedom of speech this
is the one thing i know that you'll
learn in school
cut it all out let's spread it out
welcome to the thanksgiving episode
everybody
we're dressed as well annie and i are
dressed as vegetables today and esther
is dressed in her favorite food of all
time popcorn
what if what if i came downstairs today
and i saw the
my popcorn machine and esther was just
smushed inside it
i live here now
i pour so much hot butter on you i i do
think about your popcorn machine like a
few times a week it's so good
did she make you send pictures of its
hair
no
my mom asked me about it she's like so
did anna get her popcorn machine yet i'm
like yeah mom she has it already mary
you've always got a place to stay
okay we know esther doesn't have
the best snacks sometimes she cooks some
vegan treats that we have to talk about
okay did she use salt instead of sugar
why do they look so much alike
you guys we're going to try something
new this week uh-oh since our being ugly
being hideous in costumes
since our whole show tends to be on the
edgier side we're going to try this new
exercise called wholesome 10. in the
first 10 minutes of the show we're going
to talk strictly about wholesome things
because we got demonetized on youtube oh
maybe
but after you start let's talk about
soups
i'm really gonna shine today i can't do
this i'm like one time i stuck my dick
in a suit
andy no no
okay so today's topic is soups wow wish
i had some time to prepare
um do you like soups is it a comfort
food do you make them it's really not
filling enough did you ever make soups
in your
undies
little doodoo honestly
honestly
a little mud puddle this is the opposite
of wholesome but
everybody dudes no not doo doo but like
it's a creamy amore clam chowder when i
take edibles i get so
[ __ ]
turnt
like horny yeah so you're making clam
chowder down there i'm making like
uh the icing that you dip your cinnamony
rolls from burger king in hmm i guess
that's more like manges but
this is not going well
guys wholesome 10. we listen the days of
having esther just talk about soup like
she's in third grade
and did when she started taking those
cream pie edibles that she's taking
these little cream up edibles you cannot
just tell us that we have to be
wholesome it's just going to make me and
annie go nuts and we're going to end up
eating each other out esther's a
sexual druggie now yeah
i got to stop talking
can i can you say something i think
you're okay this is my guess this is my
doctor annie
my my police office you don't want to
walk
listen my well you want to walk out of
it
um okay so esther i believe that before
you smoked weed you were riddled with
anxiety yes
your anxiety
was
uh
was making you seem a little bit younger
and you were worried about things now
that you're not worried about
pre-lexapro though like you almost have
to go
lexapro and then we okay so lexapro
[ __ ] changed everything right don't
get don't get it twisted i'm not getting
it twisted okay alexa pro you're a very
important piece of this puzzle but thank
you
you were still annoying
no but you had start anxiety and stuff
okay yeah then now
now that you're on the edibles and
you're not having this anxiety you have
all this extra time and it turns out the
extra space in your mind
is just that you're a sexual deviant
this entire time
you have been and to get where you're at
you couldn't let people know what you
are
you would never have made it you were to
look too young
like i was i would have been i would
have just been a porn star yes you would
have been a porn star yeah and some very
questionable porns okay and that would
have
it would have been a hit
let's just say i would have been hit
what categories do you guys go for oh
god miss wholesome
i um
i do love a chunky bite in a soup but i
i prefer to not go cream it's too heavy
it's super category asian soup i do i do
like pho is my favorite
yeah you like i literally know that
about i remember the first time we
talked annie on facetime you went on
about pho for a whole hour and you know
i don't like it i know a place it's so
boring too no fuzz the best are you
kidding me listen the place that the i
think it's skinny person food though so
like i'm jealous that you like it
because only if you don't eat the
noodles and only if you don't add like
the the tendons what do you get what do
you guys get in your pho i don't like
when i load it up chewy when it's chewy
the tendons the pendant's the best i
like the beef i like the cartilage i
don't like yeah the cartilage know i
like that i know you guys are
successfully having the soup
conversation but it's really hard to
know how to do your hair in the popcorn
outfit you honestly look like an nfl
linebacker not popcorn you look like
kalila hello
isn't it like upsetting that it's not
that it's fun and not faux
yes doesn't it feel bad to say
george sounds wrong suck my dick
we need to we need to call a vietnamese
um person too because sometimes i've
heard it's not even either
somewhere in between yeah
we're not getting it right the
pronunciation
yeah i thought you meant this episode
where's the magic guys we're too we're
we're just reeling off of the shoving
those things in each other's [ __ ]
episode that was so fun i know i know i
mean and and the saddest part is that
that wasn't a planned bit that was just
on the fly like you want to put stuff on
my head okay
yeah that was all of us that's just who
we are i think about this a lot it's
like we're all double downers like in
our own way like
yeah yes you're you're a downer twice
except for me i won't eat spiders sorry
but like i do feel like when it comes
like sexual body stuff we're all just
like sure put it in you like double dick
so anyways categories on pornhub you
guys just go for it like whatever is 89
up top on the part when you first you
don't what i don't watch porn i don't
either anymore but you know i hate it
what do you watch esther what's your cat
wait i don't watch porn it never felt
healthy and it never felt
i used to watch like amateurs i don't
know i just don't how do you i don't
like porn stars i don't
i don't know i mean not that i don't
like them in general but i don't like
the idea of that watching someone at
work it's like not how do you i used to
like james dean then he was a rapist
it's like
i like how rough he was if you don't
watch porn how do you j um my head
that's the best way i think my head is
not it doesn't work really no i've never
no
it's just so annoying because i just
spent the week with my parents and they
watch every [ __ ] episode and now they
know you've been flicking your beans and
it's like this is the this is the
converse like this is i hate this this
is our part of the job this is our
family george looks like he has
something to say the whole time
wholesome ten okay we're gonna hard
reset here we go hard reset we're gonna
start with i wanna ask a question before
we reset
do your parents have your parents
adopted the nickname for you go go queen
no but if you want to actually go there
and have me tell you what happened with
my parents
but we may need to cut this out but i
can't actually keep it in any longer so
i was on a warning walk with my mom and
dad the first day got to their house and
my dad goes wow kalila sure loves ass
licking
by the way you might think that's the
bad part that's that's the part that
didn't even bother me
klyla sherlo's ass licking and my mom
goes
wait a second
what skull [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh
she goes oh i just realized what it is
that's what your dad does to me yes mary
oh my god mary
good for you girl just hang back do you
want to tell al you've done enough you
do the dishes mary you do the dishes
off the trauma
the actual sexual trauma that i am
living with i like when you said sexual
trauma i just imagined a saxophone yeah
and then they brought it up again later
at dinner because it because guess what
[ __ ] holiday it was this past weekend
dia de los muertos my birthday so
there's skulls everywhere for day of the
dead at the mexican restaurant did your
dad just go up and [ __ ] all of them and
my dad just goes
to his schools and my mom's like
and i finally it got really serious and
i was like hey mom do you want to
picture your mom and dad [ __ ] doing
that and she's like oh okay so that's
what i'm dealing with thanks to this hit
show
i think that we should as a team or as
girls reclaim skull [ __ ] because it's
always been something that dudes have
you know bragged about doing to girls
and i think what they don't realize is
like we're lazy yeah we wouldn't we
don't want our neck to go back and forth
so we just take it and the jokes on [ __ ]
the jokes on that a million percent i
also will say i like the word face [ __ ]
a little better maybe because my parents
ruined skull [ __ ] for me but like
i
100 actually think that you have started
here on this show a feminist movement
that's pro
face [ __ ]
and i i i texted george i want to make
shirts that say either i want to skull
[ __ ] me i'm a slug or like face [ __ ] me
i'm a feminist because i feel like we
are creating
the positive facebook
we're manifesting that all you women out
there just lean back and open up okay no
neck movement ladies and gentlemen 20 20
years
you can't you can't if you're a slug we
don't do neck movement we don't have
necks we just lay back and take it and
they think they're doing something to us
but it's really we're winning yeah we're
not doing any work no calories burned
during [ __ ] anymore this is iconic
apparently my mom and stepdad still are
very active and um
that knowledge was that information was
dropped on me about two weeks ago excuse
me
please tell me more well you know my
mom's a [ __ ] cyborg right yeah so we
know that she probably like can hardcore
[ __ ] still but i'm really surprised my
stepdad's like well into his 70s and
he's you know he's on a lot of meds and
apparently he still likes the [ __ ] my
parents haven't [ __ ] since
my parents would always make jokes about
it and i'm like okay literally i'm just
i'm jealous i've never been more jealous
well
yeah because you don't they love each
other they're best friends now maybe
they [ __ ] i don't know there was one
actually there was one valentine's day
that's true they also might be really
good at keeping it when i was leaving
when i was when i was living at home and
i didn't have any friends my parents
were like
uh do you mind it was their anniversary
or something like can you like go out
like and i was like i literally can't i
have no friends i had no one to go hang
out with been there and i just heard
like
oh slow and slow and deep well they got
to make it last they only do it once a
decade slow fucking's good i like that
slow fast how did you feel about it both
you gotta
did it mess you up
it was gross but i was happy for them
did you does it mess you up to know that
your mom is [ __ ] your stepdad because
i have a theory because it doesn't gross
my sister out as much as it does to me
because my dad is her stepdad so i'm
like is it easier if it should be worse
it should be worse
her mom's getting plowed by some strange
man
my mom does the plowing in this one so i
don't feel as bad as your mom whip eggs
or step dad thank you guys you guys call
her up call her up
my mom i mean it's weird because they're
both control freaks so like i don't know
how that works who takes charge i feel
like you do you come in and you're like
listen
i i'm taking control of this one you are
on the bottom today you're on the top i
would love for you to do that for me and
dave but just uh choreograph something
for us to do yeah i'd love to
[Laughter]
made it too easy yet again
you really are just it's like i feel
like about the batting cages you're
doing it's like really slow
my life is so easy when i'm around it's
like people think i'm like a comedic
genius because you're such a [ __ ]
ding-dong
you're such a lay-up it's like the
easiest moments i literally were getting
out of the car i was like let's go do
our hit podcast that is the easiest
thing in the world to do
[Laughter]
it's you are a sl it is because you're a
slug
my dad literally this weekend said to me
he's like you're to me esther your
comedic strength is that you make other
people funnier yeah you really do
thanks dad
esther so you were at the airport and
you were stopped by tmz yeah
isn't that crazy
they asked and it was really
rude
well first of all he asked me about
working with britney spears boyfriend
because he did a guest spot on doll face
and then okay
wait is he the one that is he the one
that's too hot for you
he doesn't play my no he doesn't play
that role but so her current boyfriend
yeah brit they're her fiance fiance he
was on our show he's super cute he super
nice but then he was like what do you
think about pete davidson dating all the
paw girls why do he goes the tmz guy
goes why do the funny guys get all the
hot girls but it doesn't work the other
way around funny girls don't and i'm
like bro you just call me ugly like you
literally just call me ugly and i was
fine i thought we make everyone funnier
the dmz
and he felt really bad but i was like
i was like it's fine whatever like have
a nice day
what were you wearing what were you like
dressed like did you look like [ __ ] of
course i looked like [ __ ]
are you kidding me no you're wearing the
popcorn outfit
[Laughter]
but it did make me think like
i wish that i would have said like yeah
i'm a i'm a funny jewish comedian nobody
any athletes want to [ __ ] call me up
like isn't it is weird like why don't
like because why don't you say funny
things when people give you an
opportunity
no mitch
why
why are the men of podcasting
like probably being hit up a million
times on their shows and everything by
women
but that doesn't happen to us why don't
hot men hit you up is that a thing can
they not hit you yeah
sorry annie that's so sad
i get hit up by hot guys all the time
all the time
like gorgeous gorgeous man
esther honestly at least 10 a day by the
hottest men this podcast like navy seals
it's not my mental health it's not worth
it
let's just slap some lashes on every
once in a while who is hitting you
[ __ ] honestly sometimes i show jewels
i'm like look
at these men
and they're like you save me seals where
i'm like me too
me too this was not a [ __ ] this is not
a [ __ ]
no they're uh
i get
hit up by like really like
successful
gorgeous men
i think mine suffer from a little ptsd
from the
from the military but you know
oh sorry esther
maybe you're not paying attention maybe
he's like this dude you bullied yourself
george george doesn't want you either
told me she's trying to get george to
hit on her
george tell me i'm hot george holds me
in your arms
[Music]
is something preventing you from
achieving your goals uh too many things
anxiety seasonal depression
isn't that the worst
when when the seasons change and you're
still depressed oops okay i don't have
that
the sun is going down at 4 30.
oh it's not this we need help we need
better help betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist and you
can connect in a safe and private online
environment it is so convenient and you
can start communicating in under 48
hours you guys mental health is not a
joke it's not a drill
we need help with it it's very important
you cannot be happy and healthy and
manifest and all that [ __ ] if you are
not taking care of your mental health
and now it's as easy as getting on your
phone
you can start communicating in 48 hours
there's a journal feature that i love
where you can write down your thoughts
throughout the week before your therapy
session the service is available for
clients worldwide and they have licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in depression stress anxiety
lgbt matters grief self-esteem all of it
anything you share is confidential it's
convenient professional and if you are
someone who hasn't yet dipped your toe
into therapy you know maybe the money is
an issue or just you're embarrassed you
feel shame this is the perfect way to
dip your toe and get started by using
better health yeah you can avoid going
to see a therapist leaving crying
weeping and walking out and in the
waiting room is the next patient uh
avoid that by going to betterhelp.com we
want you to start living a happier life
today and as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's betterhelp
help dot com slash trash tuesday dear
santa
all i want this holiday season is for my
man to have smooth jingle balls
thankfully manscaped answered with a
performance package 4.0 so i don't have
to find stannah's beard in my pants ever
again in your man's pants in my man's
pants
ladies this holiday season get your man
products that will leave him smelling
fresh with their all new ultra premium
body wash and a two in one shampoo and
conditioner it's time to give the man in
your life the gift of beautiful skin
hair and balls this holiday season go to
manscape.com and use code trash for 20
off plus free shipping now they sent me
the shampoo and conditioner i love it
what do you use it on her man hair
i don't know about you but while i don't
mind hair i don't like an untamed bush
when i go down on my man's chimney
hairy jingle balls are a thing of the
past with manscape performance package
4.0 inside the performance package 4.0
you'll find the signature lawnmower 4.0
the perfect trimmer to keep his
christmas tree trimmed and
their hygiene bundle also comes with a
pair of manscaped anti-chafing boxers
that'll keep you
keep his junk feeling fresh all day and
i will tell you i know you wasn't saying
todd todd where's those i was i thought
maybe you were wearing them i wouldn't
be so awesome yeah 20 off plus free
shipping with a code trash at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
trash naughty or nice manscaped is the
number one gift on santa's list
but it jokes on them because i'm not
into like super glue oh i'm not into i'm
not into any dms yeah no of course i
love fat trolls though that's my
weakness i'll [ __ ] a fat troll you mean
like a short man or a man on the
internet or me
you mean like a man on the internet or a
woman sitting next to me
you mean like the like how they look
yeah i'm not really into tens like i'm
not really into um you're a naughty girl
aren't you there's a guy who's pretty
handsome
who i did a festival with
years ago in like 2012.
and he's very like educated and
successful
and he i couldn't bel i didn't know if
he was hitting on me or not
and then this is going to be so obvious
really
i i didn't think i couldn't tell if he
was hitting him or not and he kept like
kind of leaving he's like these yeah and
then it was like he owned amazon
i don't want to say his name
he did shoot up in his face in a
penis-looking thing
um i was like is he hitting him i could
never really tell and he there were like
a lot of opportunities where it felt
like he wanted me to make the move and i
was just like that's not gonna happen
and nothing happened and i was always
like i wonder and then he married my
celebrity doppelganger and i was like oh
you were
you were trying you were trying mm-hmm
um maybe he wasn't i don't know
but i remember being like saying he has
a type yeah i just was like i remember
this person with all of these i remember
i can confirm i remember you telling me
like if you worked at a gas station i'd
be like maybe he's into me do you know
what i mean like but the fact that he
was like so successful i was like little
old me it was like self-esteem thing but
i could probably bang a hot guy now but
i have a hot wonderful man i was
thinking about this i think i
i think ty did you look at me when you
said that whenever i say man i land on
you i just want to make sure you know i
don't want her to feel bad about her man
shoulders
and i want you to feel really bad
about yours i think todd is the best
boyfriend i've ever heard like written
and i'm like in the world
i don't think there's ever been a better
boyfriend not to sound like a total
nerd but i love him i had a dream that
he left me and i was very mad at him
a nightmare that he left me and randy
for a waitress
and a job as a waiter he's like i can
promise you one thing i will never leave
you for a job as a waiter but he um
i was like heartbroken i woke up like
crying i was so sad i hate those dreams
of course you have to be he did
something it's [ __ ] up do you ever
have a sex dream about someone that you
would never have thought that you would
hook up with and then like all then for
like the next week you're like looking
at that person like
like all the time or you have a
pheromone match like you ever like hug
someone and you're like oh my god what
cologne are you wearing and they're like
i'm not wearing cologne and then you're
like
like jesus wants me to have kids with
you
wait i've never had that that sounds so
fun really no it's never a good person
come in you've never had a pheromone
match
i can smell you from here it's not a
i was watching an old episode or not i
don't know what it was a couple episodes
ago or maybe it was one that didn't come
out but i was thinking about how you
were like made fun of me for my
deodorant stains and i was like oh
that's a thing you've never had to deal
with deodorant stains
that's funny i had them on the shirt
today and i tried to there's a uh was it
from a couple days ago
it was not fun
no i wore this yesterday this is my
sleepover by esther shirt i wear this i
can't believe you're wearing that that's
not even for sale i literally can't even
believe that you have not realized that
i've been the best friend you've ever
had in your entire life the whole time
because you're like i didn't wear any
today and here you are wearing it that's
the jazz top and black it's not even out
that's like and look at these pants
these are not sleepover master but
they're so good
yeah those are hot those are hot pants
i love that and
i've been training i'm getting ripped my
boots
i think you need a little [ __ ] stamp
you don't need to catch up i'll get it
yeah a little kalila yeah by the way
how's it going
it's crusty but it's wonderful my
favorite part of the whole thing is when
i gave her cowboy boots and you went how
did you still get a better present it's
like as for your present was better i
promise
you think it's better
words not a present it's not even a real
present
dave is a hater okay this is a present
to yourself
i got me something on your birthday
one time a boyfriend did do that to me
[ __ ]
well they all do that to me but
he was like this is the the one and only
narcissist i ever dated i was like oh we
we've only been together a month and i
was like i'm going back to the
philippines for six weeks blah blah blah
but it's right around christmas time so
for christmas he was like here's your
gift and he had like tears in his eyes
and he was like here's your gift he's
like i really just want to let you know
he molded your vagina for him he's like
yeah this is a really special gift and
i've never done this before and i opened
a gift and it's a plane ticket for him
to fly to the philippines
to destroy
my vacation which he very much did
and i'm like
oh thank you so much you're meeting me
there
like he he forced himself into my
vacation because i was 22 i didn't know
what to do that's like if someone gives
you a gift and it
it's like a picture of themselves in a
frame
like i always think about that like i
want to give you like a cardboard cutout
of me
but it's your size so you can finally
feel equal to me my size annie
it could fit in like an envelope
are people when when people see you on
the road or they're like oh my god you
are small
not really when i see it when when
people come up to they always like but
how tall really is esther i always like
draw on the shirts like esther is this
tall
on the bottom of the shirt where
esther's head would come up
by the way i did do the shows finally in
portland and san francisco so fun i see
what you were talking about it's amazing
it's the slugs the the they're [ __ ]
amazing they're freaks they get us
they understand us it is just like
unreal yeah i see what you i told you
i've been like guys yes
it's been so fun i'm um i'm going i'm
excited i'm going to
uh my hometown for thanksgiving to do
shows are you guys going home for
thanksgiving i don't know i have no
thanksgiving plans do you guys want to
come with me to
philly
i've never been to philly pop that rate
up wait i have a question for you guys
is thanksgiving like a big to-do in your
family absolutely not oh i'll tell you
about my family my parents go
oh we got to figure out what we're doing
for uh thanksgiving and i go todd's
parents sold the house they don't have
and they're going ah they were so so
that was like so hopeful that we were
gonna go to tots parents really oh my
parents will go to like they would end
up in skokie with your parents like my
parents will go anywhere i love that
it is good energy it is i love that
[ __ ] energy my parents love to be fed
they love laughing they love a party but
they do not want to do and nobody else
wants it either it's not their yeah it's
like when i go help people move and i
just i'm talking
yeah i know we all have our roles
live things
and i think that my family is the
inviter not the invitation oh really
like we're the people that love to bring
people in like so why don't you bring
your whole family to philadelphia rent a
place
i wonder if that is a cultural thing
because my best friend christina who's
has a very large cuban family they
[ __ ]
like
i'm open door i can always show up to
anything and that makes me feel
so amazing same yeah same it's always uh
it's like very second nature
um for us to host and to have like on
our like for instance christmas
um we always have jenna we always have
um
our jewish friends yeah and we we put
the for them we put the menorah we put
everything for them so it's uh everyone
comes for christmas and it's a big
fun can i call a games party should we
is this yeah christmas
we need to figure out our holidays we
need to coordinate holiday plans maybe
we should do like a virtual
uh christmas thing my time off
you do not get time off george this is
so ridiculous
this is time this is your time off you
get to watch us stick things in our
[ __ ]
this is your break
okay the whole your job with us is your
banana break
okay your work is at home but i will
invite you to our bonanzas our holiday
bonanzas
i didn't grow up with thanksgiving so
i'm just learning to to like it and i'm
like ugh like
turkey and like the foods don't excite
me do you associate like with the native
americans because you
like
my people
maybe maybe inherently that's why but i
don't i didn't grow up with it so it
doesn't excite me the only thing that
excites me about thanksgiving is that
it's a marker that the next day i get to
get a tree
and i'm a big christmas
is fun yeah and i'll get three christmas
trees i don't just get one i decorate
the whole house it's a big thing we're
getting we have tall ceilings now so
we're gonna get a really really really
tall oh can i help you guys do your tree
up you guys holiday season trash tuesday
this is gonna be like
really fun this is the thanksgiving one
right now no yeah but i mean like oh
okay
wait annie when are you getting a tree
don't get it too soon because it will
dry out unless you're really good at
watering it
um
well we know the answer to that
call todd yeah let's ask todd what he's
willing we are leaving too so but we're
only going to be gone for a little bit
the only thing with christmas is we're
going to go to the cowboys game the 26th
oh you go wait both of you guys are
cowboys fans or just todd is it here no
it's in uh texas but
todd todd's
uh dad is a big cowboys fan so he got
tickets for his dad because look what we
have on the board it says football
predictions what do you guys know about
football i don't know why george i know
that my boyfriend bets on it and now i'm
interested before when money wasn't
involved i was like sports i like don't
want to get now i'm like
how much are we winning oh no i'm gonna
have to have a one-on-one meeting with
you and my dad set up
what so he can teach me how to do it
he's an expert
or either of you guys he does sports
better but
yeah no
but a better is a better that's correct
it's just something he hasn't gone into
fallen into well he studies like he
watches the games when your dad sees the
skull he goes i'd better all right
but just watch squid game it's the best
it's the best way to not to kind of did
you know that game no i need to are you
[ __ ] kidding me it's over it's done
your dad needs to watch squid game
because it's like it's the story line is
about you know
a gambler who loses everything right
but then he wins
the hearts
of many netflix executives
that has netflix in every country
i have a fun fact the only broke bone
i've ever broken on my body has been
because of a football
catching very funny
look this one's crooked
because if you weren't being raped when
this happened i'm not interested
i was
it was the rape it was you were the
skins
and the scrimmage
i was skinned god i'm so sorry i was
like what other show can i i really want
to see you catch a football esther's
screaming at me and going you're too
[ __ ] ugly to get it raped can you
catch it
sure go ahead
oh my god what is this attitude look at
stoner girl get her give her a hacky
sack she'll be able to do that
oh my god i hated that i hated that and
it hurt my hand don't ever do that she
went nail first to catch it
make your predictions
um okay so the chicago bears from what i
understand growing up are not doing that
great they suck are they doing well
george
they did well for like about 10 minutes
of the of the game last night yeah it
was surprising which i actually watched
some of that because my parents are
watching it
um
your parents watch sports and trash
tuesday those are their things
and the annie the bears and us okay so
bears at lions okay so it's uh it's at
lions
in detroit so they're playing an away
game okay so it's an away game here's
the thing though the same climate so
there's no climate advantage you know
sometimes you think it's a hot a hot
team playing a cold tea very smart that
could interfere applies to baseball as
well you're very cool we got cold on
cold doesn't apply to hockey though
okay we got a cold team on a coal team
in the midwest you know what
the bears
i just i've been trained to grow up
believing that the chicago teams are
losers
what cubs not the cubs the cubs are
amazing now but it's like go back to the
90s eight like the 80s or 90s what
now they're winners they've been
wondering since the 80s and i don't know
who what their record is but it's just
funny for you to go go back to the 80s
and 90s the cubs are like famous losers
i'm imagining yeah i'm imagining esther
in like a onesie as a baby and it's a
it's a cubs onesie but they've crossed
out the cubs
they're like we got to let this baby
know that's true because they they
played us um
um they always play us in the um the
national league championships the
dodgers by us i mean dodgers and the
year that they beat us they went on i
don't know why i thought it was your
actual family
you should see them at the beginning
dude travis ravina is my family but they
went on to win the world series and that
that was like the first world series in
like what like 50 years or something so
you're not wrong
they've lost a long time but bear is
that lions esther what's your name wait
can i just tell you something i remember
about sports that i'll never forget
there's this really mean dog on the
other side of the fence and if you hit
the ball over the fence
it's really hard to get it you got to
try to go get it james earl jones is in
the house
uh and it turns out the dog is actually
really friendly i love that movie
number one benny was so hot but do you
remember when yeah
i really didn't see that i don't know i
knew it i just know the name but did you
not see it i did see it are you lying
i'm not lying i don't remember it in
detail but i remember the scary dog and
the over the fence you guys i mean i
feel like in 101 dalmatians you thought
it was scary dogs too but
the kid the hot kid in it okay this is
i'm a kid in this telling this okay kid
watching the thing
i do remember the feeling my vag got
though same when i watched little giants
with um devon sawa
yeah is his name
someone said what's up
no no cool
and someone corrected me like our old
like crushes from on on the show i think
we can get him on the show he's really
funny yeah he's cool
he's friends with me at the improv we
can get it macaulay culkin is for
they're always tweeting at each other
making questions my god i remember the
night
wait what's when esther brought macaulay
culkin to the comedy story he was in the
back and esther's like it's normal for
her to see macaulay's logan it is not
[ __ ] humble for me i'm trying to act
all serious and normal formal and then i
was like everything's fine and
it's not this very important person in
my life
and uh everything's cool and then i'm
sitting down next to him like all stiff
i'm looking at the ticket booth and the
one the girl working is arguing with
this guy and sending him away and it's
[ __ ] ben savage and i was like
i was like freaking out and then i ran
out i was like ben savage don't she's
canadian she doesn't know like who you
are she doesn't know she's not from here
i'm winning i'm winnie
my name is my big wide face i'm like
he just walked in the gucci fashion show
did you guys see that on um hollywood
[ __ ] how sick is that
i thought you were gonna say on
something
because that just seems like a thing you
would do on drugs
we should have him on we'll have them
all on but we can't be normal he's funny
too if he's really funny he was crazy on
your special he was funny he was sophie
he's really funny devin sawa and devon
sawa andrew keegan has a church but i
had a big old crush he's a kombucha king
he also like has very like
highly concentrated kombucha which the
fbi cracked down on him for i i keep
thinking you're going to say something
you're not saying at all like when
you're like he has really high i think
he's a high voice i was like oh my god i
got a high voice that's a bummer but
andrew keegan was uh you know who i was
i was so obsessed with them who i had
the hots for was the hot friend on
the hot friend on boy meets world oh
ryder strong
i think so yeah with like the mushroom
cut yeah yeah he was hot
i know that's sad though we gotta give
you a mushroom cut you're wearing his
outfit you're wearing ryder strong
with liquid death there available back
then
do you guys think he's hot too i think
he had like i did swag compared to corey
jensen married topanga our friend jensen
carp married to pango yeah she's so cute
anyways guys how did we get here from
football predictions because you have a
podcast with annie letterman that's how
okay you know it's fun looking at little
boys we used to look our beans too
yeah
that's the sport i play we're all
winners in this sport
who else did you masturbate to did you
watch camp nowhere
you didn't watch camp nowhere no what is
it i want to punch you i want to take
you as the football i want to [ __ ]
make sure you're a spiral [ __ ] stick my
finger right up that ass
i want to throw you across the field i
think that we should do this i think for
the next episode
because i know you're into vision boards
i think we should make a collage
of
i don't know why she's laughing but i
know it's offensive towards me
it's offensive towards me for sure what
a loser basic [ __ ] she's like she's
like we know you're into vision boards
it's like saying i know you like
i know you like crappy
i know you like lattes
and puppies esther is
she's the she's a very odd basic that's
what you are that i know you you're a
weird base you know you always used to
say this you would say that i
so desperately want i like present as
basic but i'm actually not really
something really up with you the world
knows now
my dudes
how many free trial subscriptions end up
costing you hundreds if not thousands of
dollars long after you forget to cancel
like this is a real thing i've been
trying to just avoid it but it's you
can't eventually your card no longer
works what a shock it was for me to
actually look through my phone and all
my subscriptions that i had unknowingly
been paying for for years dude fight
back against scammy subscriptions with
truebill
truebill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't need want
or you simply just like forgot about on
average people save up to 720
a year with drew bill i think i'm owed
about seven thousand dollars worth of
workout clothes from one subscription i
signed up for accidentally in 2013. i
know which one it is wait is it yes okay
but here's the thing because companies
make subscriptions hard to cancel true
bill makes it incredibly simple just
link your accounts and trouba will
cancel your unwanted subscriptions in
one tap and your true bill concierge is
there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to triple has over 2 million users and
help save them over a hundred million
dollars didn't you say you saved like
three hundred dollars when you started
first using yes i'm saving so much money
it's crazy it's it actually is so
embarrassing how much money i'm saving
it's embarrassing well also because i
kept thinking like i would get a
subscription to something and think i
have like the family subscription for
everyone in my family then you find out
each member of my family is also paying
for it it's like you guys don't fall for
subscription scams start canceling today
at truebill.com
trash tuesday go right now truebill.com
trash tuesday it could save you
thousands a year truebill.com
trash tuesday
and we could all use a stiff breeze yeah
fall is here and we want us there's one
thing we don't want to see fall this
episode is sponsored by bluechu
you guys confidence can take you far in
life and it can also help in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate that's where bluechew comes
in bluechu is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost so you can take them anytime day or
night and you can plan ahead and be
ready whenever an opportunity arises i
just feel like if you're someone that
has maybe thought about needing a
product like this this is the perfect
way they make it easy
and convenient it's just normal this is
the future baby back in the day they
just had to deal with those noodles it's
all done online no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discrete package and how
exciting imagine seeing the postman
being like hey
those are my yay
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try blue
chew free when you use our promo code
tuesday at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code tuesday to receive your first
month free
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast ladies blue chew is exclusively
for men but the end result is something
you will both enjoy so get your man to
sign up
good for christmas
yeah you're the ultimate american psycho
i think
what that movie was made it was a
autobiographical you two are monsters
you are insane that's how you you know
that's how you present oh my god annie
that's how she [ __ ] she looks at
herself in the mirror when she's [ __ ]
someone shut up you [ __ ]
yes there's the american psycho oh you
guys are in there do you ever are you
ever not sure if it's you or dave with
the hair
you're like oh damn i look oh wait
that's dave no do you want to know that
something like that one time dave took a
selfie of us no [ __ ] i [ __ ] up the
story one time we took a selfie in bed
and i was like my arm looks really
skinny and it was [ __ ] dave's arm
you're like my penis looks thick
[Laughter]
oh my god wait i want to talk about
little boys we had crushes on them yeah
next episode next episode we bring
because
we should talk to society and be
wonderful
because kevin bacon
okay he was always like a little old for
me but i had a crush on him when i
watched friday the 13th and he was like
14. that's why
i was 14. three to five cutouts on uh
what do you call a cartolina uh what do
you call those poster boards poster
board a cartelina cartelina is like post
oh it's turning me on say it again yeah
say it again and so we put it in a
cartolina right
four three to five pictures of our
crushes and then we're in a manifest
we're gonna do a seance to see who we
get on the show we got a ouija board and
[ __ ] on here yeah i will be honest with
you
i've always been the one that pushes it
that's fine
what they want
we don't have time come on guys it's
like if we believe in manifestation then
we should have at least two of our boy
crushes on the on the show i wonder who
it would be though do they have to be
crushes from like when we were younger
or can it be someone like we wish we
could [ __ ] right now celebrity so we
already have that
imagine
imagine like um leonardo dicaprio is
going to be on there for me like now
imagine
oh esther
you didn't stan
i did love leonardo dicaprio when i saw
titanic of course was it because again
the head face shape is similar like how
i felt with windy
you do have a look
are you really right now telling me i
look like leonardo dicaprio in titanic
it's honestly the best compliment i i
know since tmz
harassed you do you remember when we
were in montreal and the people came up
that's an amazing story you should tell
it but not say the names of who please
tell them we were in a okay we went to
montreal we got this was our epic flight
where we ran into jordan woods and yeah
and everyone's on our plate the guy [ __ ]
our pants his pants in front of us
esther and i have had fun in planes so
we get off this flight this van picks us
up to go to this festival and picks up
like seven comedians seven comedians and
there are some on there that we are
they stink okay they stink in a lot of
ways
i wasn't gonna say that part but but
they stink it's just like they're not
they ain't [ __ ]
um and they think that you should so
anyway so with these with these comics
and um this like man comes up with a
camera and all these like photos and
he's like oh my god well you saw will
you autograph these and
yeah to them not us yeah
and we're like esther and i were like
what oh my god like we're like
them like this is them and they like
really we were just thinking about how
like
they're why are they even here yeah
what's going on yeah they're so famous
that they're getting asked for
autographs it was like stopped at the
airport we're like what the hell so we
were just like we we basically got like
our ass handed to us we were like oh
okay we're wrong yeah and then the guy
came over to us with it we're like okay
and he had our headshots
it's like we're all nobodies okay guys i
was like all right this is a nobody's
thing this really means nothing okay
but it was so funny just our looks
across the room to each other like
so it is fun to get your ass handed to
you but with someone else to be like oh
we're yeah we're literally now we're
bound
so what is our collective um
well it's not collective because i am
assuming we have different airport
styles but what is our airport style
like how you look yeah like what is yeah
you go for comfort you go for glam like
what do you i glam if i have a show that
night just because i don't have time i
like i'm not gonna have time and it is
like when you go in with your like
clip-on you have to go to the girl it's
always like the tsa girl's like we just
it's fine oh they have to cut your head
down and they're like it's fine i can't
imagine traveling like done up that
sounds like
it makes i don't know
like when i feel like when i land the
done up would be gone mm-hmm like i
would look ugly don't you really what
are you doing on these planes
i don't know rubbing your face on things
how do you sleep on planes are you able
to put your feet down and knock back i
will say
i
the the masks are a gift because i used
to have to put my
eye mask over my mouth
to keep my jaw from
falling a gap i look like what i look
when i go on a on a plane i fall asleep
so fast i look like my parents have to
make a decision whether or not to unplug
them i am like
there's drool it's so and it's not i
can't control it you're dave so i have
to put a mask asleep at me mask i have
to put myself a sweater over your face
it's my carry-on that's so annoying it's
like slashing you gotta empty it out
before you go through well it's a
medical device so you actually get that
as a free extra carry-on i used to
because so are you a medical device he
gets to carry on like listen she's an
issue
just let her hold on you're supporting i
have a a long very movable neck
so i don't i cannot sleep this way what
also what
so i have a very floppy neck
i have a big head what are you saying
what i'm saying is i have to tie a
sweater before those you know now they
have those things that kind of uh you
can pull this way on the plane seat yeah
yeah yeah before that i would have to
get a sweater thin sweater tie it across
my forehead tie it to the back of the
seat and keep my head in place like this
that sounds genius that actually is such
a good idea yeah that's how it would
cover my whole face that i would look
like it's also really good for skull
[ __ ] so if you guys are looking for a
new uh way to really stay still let's
try it out anna get your dick out but
you know what uh actually fixes all of
this uh fly first class ah
you gotta get in them lay downs
the the thing that pisses me off is when
you get a good first class deal like a
good um price
and then you realize there's not a lie
down a live flat seat and you're like
well it's not worth it yeah oh you have
to tell ahead of time you have to see
yeah it is still worth it because
they're nicer to you you get on first
it's easier i thought people don't talk
to you the way that they talk to you and
because it's true i thought of you this
weekend because i was flying in coach
and it sucked no because i i bought
myself internet which i normally don't i
have a membership for the year i always
have monthly she's a baller i'll tell
you where you we won't be getting you i
know what money is for money is to make
you comfortable while you're doing what
you're on this earth to do and what
we're on this earth to do is to
entertain and make people feel good and
make them laugh if flying over there
is stressful is you're like crowded you
feel unsafe you feel sneezed on you feel
like the flight attendant is rude your
bag didn't make it on you're stressed
out you're not here doing what you want
to do so all the money that you make
goes into your comfort zone i hate to
break it to you guys but on our flight
on hawaiian airlines um the five hours
over the pacific does not have wi-fi
so we have to entertain each other are
you [ __ ] i'm also not in first class
because i wanted to stay humble i saw
both of your guys's confirmations you
guys have like comfort plus and yeah i'm
waiting for
the nosebleed you didn't get comfort
plus
no upgrade george
wait if george got comfort plus i should
just kill myself yeah got it so i copied
her yeah i copied her too i'm not going
to walk back there
i will walk back there to say hi to you
to give you one of our treats that's
what i've done when i fly my friend's
fly coach you go back you give him
something for like did you want a glass
of champagne i don't drink i feel like i
give you free drinks i fly hawaiians so
much i know what they're you should get
dressed on the plane what do they serve
it's a chicken bake it's the same
[ __ ] chicken bacon wait does
everybody get it everyone gets it you'll
get the same chicken bacon maybe should
we brought her fish on the plane with us
oh my god we should we fly sugar fish
airlines
wait i want to know what um our planned
outfits are you're i know you're gonna
be in a dog and a cat you're gonna bring
i'm gonna bring i'm gonna get a carrier
big enough for you also side note dave
might be dave who literally got this
trip going is now maybe not coming with
todd is going to be is bobby coming no
well we could get him to go
we need a we need
todd cannot just be he's going to end up
working for george if david isn't coming
i might have to bring my phil in carlos
yeah yeah
that's not what todd's gonna want hang
out with carlos
he wants to hang out with someone with
the job
[Music]
[Laughter]
if carlos comes he's going to be at work
he works here now
oh poor todd we'll just have to make him
film us right behind the scenes he's a
boy so dave's not going how are you
going to survive no you mean how are you
going to survive because now you're
scared that i'm going to cling to you
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you mean [ __ ] no i get to be your
handler no i'm going to have to [ __ ]
get carlos to come okay yeah carlos look
at you you really don't want to take
care of me on the trip
oh
you know what you know who's gonna be
taking care of you mama and papa okay
are gonna take care of you yeah and
daddy will be skull [ __ ] mommy just
the way he does at home
[Laughter]
i'm gonna have todd's skull [ __ ] me
tonight
i'm gonna try to [ __ ] you know it's no
not november i'm gonna try to [ __ ] every
day this week
we need our own version of no no no like
all nut yeah something i don't know what
it is um mixed nuts
three swingers
i think we should do a more nut november
or not if you if you usually masturbate
twice a week now you're gonna masturbate
four times we have to make it december
because this is the end of the night i
know what december yeah yeah what
dicks are december but we're gonna come
hard november but also if you're lesbos
you are into i want you squirting okay
this is squirt december no or if you no
not november should have been like if
you are if you hook up with a guy he
makes you come but you don't make him oh
i had a whole take back the night summer
remember that yeah oh really oh yes oh i
had a whole summer where i was like you
can come eat me out don't touch me other
than that i love that leave we're not
and they always think i'm gonna do
something no no i told you i had a time
because i like i can't tell you how many
guys i like begged me to hook up with
them in this damn comedy scene
finally they'd like break me down they'd
make me think they wanted i was that
they they really liked me you [ __ ] them
once they don't make you come and then
they're like we should just be friends
i'm like that's literally what i said
the whole time so all that happened is
you used my body i'm a sock you [ __ ]
me
to come and now you just know that and
now this just exists for no reason
so then i had a summer where i was like
all right when they'd hit me up and i'm
like come over i have a question about
that though
because while i have have done that
where i'm like can you just eat me out
like and just leave they usually ask if
they can jerk off
um around me
around some sort of yeah the proximity
and i usually allow it and would you
allow it on to them to jay on you oh
yeah i'm not afraid to come i like being
like nutted on but if you cannot we all
do i mean i think we do i might have
some flakes on my which is weird because
this morning it was my most traumatic
experience as a child
i took back the night of that too i've
reclaimed getting nutted on
so we've in this show we've learned that
we've reclaimed skulls
[ __ ] is not for them it's for us this
is by the way this is what happens when
you start the show by saying we have to
talk about soup
there's gonna you guys are gonna have to
take some parts from the in between
where we're like
no you should george should hire three
like lookalikes to sit in the chair the
first ten minutes
three toddlers
give me my banana george it's time
i did a cold plunge and uh sauna it was
so did you record it i did yeah i did
it's embarrassing where did you do it at
my friend's friend's house but i did
three minutes todd did it with me
three months is long i felt really like
i just like to lacy i was like i trust
you i was like in it like
i was like i trust you i want to get
into that
it's a good double dog dare yes did you
get benefits like how did you how did it
what did it do to you well it helped me
like i honestly like headspace wise it
really helped me because it's so
shockingly cold and your body starts
like kind of convul like it's you feel
you go through a bunch of stages i
didn't go through as many stages as she
said you could go through but it could
be really really painful
and i just remember feeling like because
i've been in like a situation where i've
been a little bit
like trying to get out of fear in a
situation and it was helping me with
that because i was like
i was told that this was gonna happen i
was told this is gonna be okay so i have
to trust
that this is like okay and i like got
through it and made me feel good about
gave you confidence yeah cause it made
me feel like less scared i guess and
then um
we did the song after it felt great did
you have like a
like did you notice a difference in like
the way your body has pain like did you
i didn't i didn't hurt but todd was
still like really in pain but he hasn't
worked out at all so she when she worked
him out it was like
and she told me that todd
could have like a perfect body she's
like he has like the great great
freaking bodybuilders
he's so cute i love him um one time at
pismo beach i guess this is where alfred
hitchcock got his inspiration for the
movie the birds oh i thought it was
esther
he saw her tmz came up and was like are
you the girl from the birds can i just
say that is the best thing you've ever
said to me
i love alfred hitchcock i love the birds
thank you so much you just swim around
people's heads annoying them they're
scared of you you ruined their day
there's a swarm of birds there and that
was the closest i ever got to
hypothermia um i was
surfing
by surfing i mean i'm going straight no
left right beginner [ __ ] right and i
wasn't wearing a wetsuit and my body
started to kind of give out on me and i
buried myself under sand watching alfred
hitchcock's birds trying to like was
anyone who saw myself yeah he was the
narcissistic boyfriend who probably went
out and got a burrito he was doing well
he was like dying he just left right out
of that situation yeah but i remember
just burying myself there and thinking
like this is how i die watching these
birds the idea that you need to bury
yourself is so amazing because in the
hot sand that was the only thing i knew
what to do i was like
in the water i go would you go back in
i love the feeling of being buried in
the sand oh don't say that around the
yard
wait why
you're going to get married in the day
really when i was little we my parents
when i was like we know and then they
left you yeah
like eight hours later have you not seen
the videos of people trying to rescue
people buried in the sand what happens
to them
you can be catastrophic very quickly
really yeah and you could actually die
i'll give you a penis though we'll bury
you and i'll build you a penis we just
need to drop you down there with a rope
so you can sort of like pull yourself up
but we're going to bury your well you do
kind of remind me you remind me of the
girl from the ring
yes amara i have a niece named samara
that's a pretty name yeah samara is her
name my best friend in high school was
named samara one of my best friends um
we saw that movie together yeah
i was so scared i remember looking at
him
get away from me
um okay so i was i was talking to todd i
was like i want to get lasered but i
want to leave like a little hair and i
was like i want to leave like a dorito
and todd's like isn't that what
isn't that um what lesbians get
the what the dorito and i was like todd
does like lesbo porn so i was like maybe
that's
you know what he knows more than me um i
saw a tweet by my friend asakira
yesterday and it was um her hand over
her like vagina over her lips but she
had a full bush and i was like oh my god
that's so hot
i had full bush but was it was it sai
like the lips i had i'll show you the
picture
i don't want i just i wouldn't mind like
just the merkin of it all really
just the top part a little bit yeah i
guess that i feel like that's what most
guys actually are drawn
i don't want to look like you know in um
dogma the
oh you like that so that's like just
like a little bit of a light it looks
like a light shaving on the
bottom parts yeah that's good i feel
like that's what guys are into i think
so too
i think who cares i think it's kind of
like what i like no of course
but but i don't mean like
esther we don't think that you're
worried about the male gaze don't worry
[Laughter]
maybe the gays but not the male gays
don't worry esther you don't have to
defend yourself
we know you just didn't mean what you
said
um esther you sent me a text um today
and you're like what are your thoughts
on the metaverse and i didn't really
know how to respond
esther care to explain i don't know and
i'm sure this is just a boring topic but
haven't you guys been starting to hear a
lot about the metaverse
it's basically this idea that it's like
an iteration of the internet that's 3d
so we have virtual reality we have these
things right you're living you're living
3d in the internet kind of like it's
like a 3d world around the sims
yeah but really a lot more technologies
oh better right todd was saying that he
feels like our apartment seems like an
apartment we would have made in the sims
oh that's cool like everything that we
get but i want to get a putting green i
want to make it so fun
i got randy a um
a dog bed that is the shape of a
philly's hat
it's so cute would dave allow you to do
um a vr like second life relationships
whoa
that's a weird texture
like like you're choosing and but also
can can a real person compete with a vr
person a vr person i am so is he in the
metaverse right now
he that's he's in the meta version i'm
into this because while all of you nerds
are doing this i'm going to be making
real money building a real empire i do
wonder the metaverse freaks me out
because it's like i'm not interested but
then i also don't want to get left
behind this is the guy i saw
i i saw mark zuckerberg on in kauai when
i was there and he had his head covered
in like this giant like hat that goes
like like a beekeepers thing and he was
in his little zodiac and everybody knows
who he is but i don't want to
point out that his wife is asian and
that is what the asian women wear on
mm-hmm
outfit they wear those yeah yeah yeah
it's for sun protection you're right
i here's i have a thought on the
metaverse i feel like everyone
has been planning for this metaverse
like all the you know gatekeepers the
billionaires whatever but don't you feel
like postcovid
the metaverse is the exact opposite of
what i want like i have been sitting at
home and living on my phone and now i
want to go out and experience real life
but this this could mimic real life for
a lot of people in fact like people fall
in love in second life how do you know
you are meeting how she wanted
her okay no i just watched um
that um
one black mirror episode where they fall
in love oh i love that one yeah um but
um i was thinking are we if offered
if this is your opportunity
i was listening to another person for
once
if they offer us to exist in the
metaverse our likeness and everything
do we do we agree or do we not i don't
know
we're gonna get left behind if we don't
george you're supposed to be on this top
of this [ __ ] what you watched it what's
your george you wear glasses you're
supposed to be on the top of this george
you're dressed as a character i'm kind
of a nerd's voice so it seems like you
can read i think it's huge i think it's
the future i don't like it
here's the thing i here's what i am very
this is how i feel i want to go
i want my life to be flow and not
resistance i don't want to look at this
and go this is gonna be the worst thing
that ever happened right it's gonna ruin
everything because it's [ __ ] awesome
it's amazing it's incredible that
technology has come and it's it's helped
us with so much like medical stuff like
every new technology has been great and
everyone can talk [ __ ] on the internet
and talk [ __ ] on social media and stuff
but
it's made our lives more convenient it's
awesome it's entertaining it's it's
everything so this i don't think can is
i i can't say that this is like a
horrible thing i do understand where it
seems dangerous and it's like i watched
westworld i get it the robots could take
over
we're we're not having real experiences
we're not going out maybe it's not the
healthiest thing but it is what's
happening and maybe there is some good
there too there's definitely some good
yeah i accept it all it looks so awesome
it does look awesome looks like he's in
mist wait okay if esther you and i saw
each other in the metaverse and we
locked eyes across right and we have a
relationship there do you think that
they would be okay with your second life
but are you both there doing it like no
no no we're in separate homes but we're
seeing each other in the metaverse and
we're scissoring the [ __ ] out of each
other how would that get what would that
get me we're not doing it i feel like
esther would be
virtually giving herself a penis by the
way i didn't think it would be
scissoring
esther would have a big old [ __ ] that's
that's the thing you
i
i don't know this is a weird thing
because i'm like what are things even
like this is questioning making me
question so much because i'm like oh i
would rather like have the
have the couch in my house and not in
the metaverse but then i'm like what
does the couch in my house even mean
like i don't know maybe we already are
in the metaverse high potential to be a
shut-in though never leave the house if
you don't you love you know your
metaverse like well you get to really
see like do are you getting healthy for
yourself or other people does bobby
isn't there like metaverses already in
the like
he like what does he say about that he
was into it for a little bit and then i
don't know he kind of i don't know you
know what sucks too if you get motion
sickness vr is like a no-go
so like anyone that gets like which it's
like you have to get cars like i don't
get cars like your whole everything you
are is a lot your brand is [ __ ] up
wire i just tear the shirt off burn it
um
but it's like so then are all these
people will be having like this great
time and then there's these other people
but i don't think anything is ever gonna
mis is is gonna ever replace
real human
touch and interaction i just don't think
yeah how could it right
i also realized that like my love
language is definite physical touch yeah
it's my number one
i need it so much i like it a lot yeah
yeah i like it too i think words of
affirmation i like more though oh really
i couldn't give two [ __ ] because i don't
words are so cheap to me but i think i
might be growing
out of that though because i do i'm the
more confident i get the more i don't
like need external validation
yeah so then i guess it would be touch
but then i'm like don't also don't touch
me yeah
i don't know
quality time too quality time is good
and physical acts of service ain't bad
being done or given to
imagine
tapes with acts of service you know
what do you think dave's uh love
language is well i should know i've been
with him for nine years i think it's
physical touch physical touch yeah and
like mine for the first few years mine
was gifts
[Laughter]
but now i make my own money and it's no
longer gifts it's just so funny there's
just you go into one of the closets in
esther's house and it's all these empty
tiffany boxes
no david can you imagine if you just got
the hackiest gift i love david he is a
terrible gift giver what has he gotten
you tell us the worst top three worst
dave gifts i'm gonna get in so much
trouble because literally then you'll
tell some good ones every there are none
no i love you david love you love you
but we all love dave our first
valentine's day and we had already been
together for like seven months and we
were very like a we're a thing
he got me
a mug
it didn't say anything what was it just
it was like pretty it was just a green
mug and i was like am i your co-worker
what is going on is this a secret santa
coworker no in his defense which he did
have a really cute defense he said like
you had been making tea recently and it
had like a little tea steeper but still
it really did
oh my god there was a tea steeper on it
you [ __ ] it was probably like a three
hundred dollars it was not a thoughtful
gift you are a [ __ ] you know what you
said it was a green mug yes i thought it
was just a mug
wait can i just say
a headache had a headache for his whole
life life
a lingering headache oh i used to do a
bit about this men don't need gifts
that's kind of true and they don't need
birthdays either that is kind of true
honestly can i just say that i like
just
to the audience helpful men that's
literally all
that's all i crave and need in the world
just helpful boys just be a helpful boy
it's hot just be helpful it's like and
if you strike out in your 20s and your
third they're going to like it in the
30s yeah well
i i think that that might still be a
little sweeter than bobby's first gift
okay
he got me i don't even think he looked
at what he got me honestly i think he
went through um he went through vons
went through the gift card
and just grabbed i think he just did
this to his hand and took the first
i have verizon and he gave me a t-mobile
gift card
right and he got me out what did he say
did he say did he say here call someone
who cares no this is how he did it annie
he got me asked him to you and like one
other thing it was like fuddruckers or
something like the place i don't go but
was it to be funny no he wasn't t-mobile
yeah i was like i have verizon this
isn't gonna work for me and then he did
this from across the table also a phone
card is like are we in a foreign country
are we in [ __ ] mexico
this is eight years ago
but he did this he just slid it one by
one across the table he's like hope you
like these these are great this is great
it was a bit
no you know it was a bet
i think my gifts are far more romantic
our first christmas together think about
this think about bobby okay bobby's like
look i'm just a [ __ ] comedian i only
have a specific set of skills okay
there's things i'm never gonna know how
to do and probably gift giving is not
one of them or knowing what a woman
wants
that's true for for our first christmas
together because our thing was the show
that we bonded over was my 600 pound
life
um
and like so tlc shows like all the
butter
and it's like we love like dr now dr now
is our hero
um he does all of the bariatric
surgeries for these patients and we
really get like we follow the life like
bobby follows like nine out of the ten
like
the tenth pro passed away there are some
that pass away after bariatric surgery
r.i.p but like he follows their journey
like it really says
after they pass away
oh
what is the rule about that what
do you unfollow after someone passes
away is there a rule i don't it's hard
to do because mingus the panther passed
away like last year and i don't know i
should unfollow it was a black cat with
a little wood fangs yeah
well i would say keep following i think
their mommy gets a new baby i know
pumpkin director oh and r.i.p that was a
big heartbreak for me
if you sneeze around me and i even
suspect you're sick and follow
i want to get ahead of this one
but i got him i printed out not pictures
of myself for christmas but pictures of
the contestants and i made like a
collage for him of our favorite not
contestants
[Laughter]
yeah for christmas and he keeps he still
has it in his car he just shoves it in
the glove compartment why is it in the
car that's what i'm really wondering i i
have pictures in the car too what
because you want them with you and then
you don't ever clean your car it's like
a wallet back in the day when you'd like
here yeah i've given some great gifts
too and i think i think that's the thing
we can't
compare ourselves to what that like we
can't expect from them what we can give
to them we're thoughtful oh speak to
bobby because he fully expressed three
thousand dollar jacket for me every year
he does todd got me
flame throwers
i have [ __ ] todd is such a good gift
giver flame throwers and he got me a
white gum pad or wacom like something
you can draw
on which i haven't used and he thinks he
talks about it he goes oh you're not
gonna and i go todd it's like
you know you could have bought yourself
another pair of yeezys instead of this i
will use it eventually but i can't be
pressured in using the gift you know
what i've always done a no gift like for
the last like six years like no gift
policy i don't want a gift because i
always like i get my parents were just
saying this like you esther you cannot
hide it when you don't yeah i don't have
christmas face i can't pretend i like uh
oh you have it that's interesting you
have it so
also it's called being rude and a bad
actor honestly as an actress this is
really bad news for you no don't worry
i'm just rude
for me it's just him rude um
i think we should do a holiday
gift
and really try to do good gifts and like
give it a spending limit that's kind of
high okay and like actually try to get
each other good gifts okay we got a
competition yeah
so we should what do you what's a good
like high but not crazy it's just weird
because she already got a tattoo so it's
like well that's not even a real gift
you're really downplaying maybe the most
epic
most romantic gesture of all time
it was like the notebook in one gesture
you died together of alzheimer's should
we have to do like a 500 gift for each
person honestly this is no offense to
you guys but i do not want to get you
guys 500 gifts
i want i was going to up the price
wait that's hilarious why
i mean i love you guys but like that
could go to you know
what
getting the dog's thing removed
the tumor removed from his neck um
no offense to the dog but if i don't get
a 500 present from kalila
that thing's getting popped george
what's your solution here everyone gets
an air fryer from me and that's it
i already have one oh damn it
how about this will will do it but um
but we get it taken out of her
portion of the pay
from george because she ends up paying
for it look i don't think you should be
five hundred dollars i think that it
should be
if we really are friends and know each
other it should be something that's
personalized for the person that you
know the person really likes it
shouldn't be a price tag see but that's
what gift giving is it shouldn't be like
something expensive it should be
something that means something i gave
can i tell you the best i really like
knowing a price limit though because
that gives me like the creative like
freedom within that what what
i think don't go over 500 but don't be
mad if kalila like
glued some cheerios together for you
you know what i mean i will be mad so i
can't do that
i'm down with that game but
kalila's
i guess she has a broke mindset
and she's going to need to do some
virtual realities you know what we have
to do is we could get each other a gift
and then kalila has to look and that
gets nothing we both maybe we have to
pick like a cause that we donate to for
kawaii are you [ __ ] kidding me
i'd rather buy the [ __ ] a star one of
those things they're like i'm about to
stop oh my god
i'd rather buy the [ __ ] did you ever
did any of your boyfriends or chickens
when people buy you chickens they go we
bought you these chicks in this country
what are you talking about me chicks
yeah and they just send you a picture of
any chip i'm like that's not my chick
bring them here fly them out can i have
them i wanted chickens i have a really
bad christmas uh christmas face for when
people tell me that they bought their
girlfriend stars
that and i'm like
it's just like uh
congratulations if you give me a [ __ ]
ticket to go up and see it i'll be cool
with that okay which star if you can
point it out if you can point it out
this is a ticket to a [ __ ] rocket
ship or i don't know actually if you're
going to buy me i want the milky way
buy me the milky way okay i wonder how
many people have the same star too do
you think they're just it's got to be a
ratchet oh yeah it's a racket for sure
all right so i got okay i watched with
my ex-boyfriend from years and years ago
curtis
um
we watched this documentary that my
friend sean donnelly made
called
are we alone
are we alone now and it's about tiffany
had two stalkers and one of the soccer
guys
i think we're alone now yeah i think
we're luna oh yeah
you said we're alone or something i
don't know okay i think we're lonely
yeah
so he okay so one of the stalkers got in
trouble because he brought her
uh uh like a samurai a katana i think
and
ten cart white carnations it was
something along those lines and it was
like it's a it's the highest honor
of assam there was some like reason
behind it it was like an honor to bring
it to her but he got in trouble because
it wasn't you know obviously a weapon so
i had watched that with my boyfriend and
then for christmas i got him the sword
and the flowers and he was like
thank you and i was like i think he
actually liked he might have liked it
but then i also we had like a little bit
when we had first started dating there
was like this we had started dating over
halloween and there was this like candy
ear and we just kept putting in each
other's things so like we would leave
and you'd open your bag and you'd have
like the evening oh that's cute so i got
him
a bot i found the candy then i got him
like a box filled with them so he opened
it and all the ears fell out did he
appreciate it yeah i mean we broke up
but i think we should close that song
he's my friend i think
children behave
that's what they say when we're together
and watch how they play i got excited
isn't this gonna get us demonetized even
more than talking about jizz on my
forearm
they don't understand
i don't remember i was so weird you
thought that was a good part that i was
listening to i was like i might have
some flakes oh my god you guys thank you
so much you should put that in the
beginning
thank you so much for tuning in we got
the sign from george it's time to wrap
it up the white man keeping the women
down
keeping us from our audience imagine if
he goes home and still [ __ ] his wife
and she just like well david there's
only option is called [ __ ] no he
plays her this episode
you guys empower it yes no this is for
empowerment
um
it's thanksgiving this is our
thanksgiving we should say what we're
grateful for when we go right now we
should have planned that before we
wrapped no before we did the what sports
teams do you dum-dums like that know
nothing about sports
george is done dude
you know what
tune in next time to hear about how our
thanksgivings went and we'll tell you
what we're grateful for also you better
be in philly seeing me this week right
now we love you guys love you
that's all bye for now
[Music]
you